all right
thank you for your patience
and we're welcoming our
linkedin
audience as well
welcome everybody to our expert webinar
in tech revolution the journey so far
the trends for 2022 and career
you
our guest today is yogendra singh who's
a partner of proteum india it's a
leading fintech
firm
and just a quick note
you can enter questions for your gender
at any time into the q a
panel of webex
if you're watching on the live stream
you can enter those into your
comments or chat
and we'll take those toward the end of
the hour
in the q a portion
we also have a couple of questions
one before and one after eugendra's
presentation so let's start with this
and
get a feel for the audience how many uh
what or how many years of experience do
you have in the workplace
we're not asking about fintech
experience we're just asking about
general experience
the second part of this
poll is how are you doing today we've
been asking this since the beginning of
the pandemic to see
how people are responding to lockdowns
coming and going and surges rising and
falling
so it's just to check in with you
and we have about 10 more seconds on the
pole
and
here we are
here's the result
uh yogendra as you can see we have an
audience that is primarily
people with five or more years of
experience
you have some folks who are still in
school and people
in the less than five years experience
category
it's good to see that everybody
is doing either
well or in the middle with just a few
exceptions and we hope that this
webinar will
help to
improve your outlook on your
future
so with that in mind
i'm going to
introduce
gender singh
excuse the typo it should say partner
proteum india
um
a
preeminent engineering-led um
risk-focused lender in india
with
he has individually 21 years of
experience
um
with
various
uh major organizations and at protium he
leads development of the underwriting
and decision making models
and he spearheads
the consumer lending business both
secured
and unsecured so
we're very fortunate to have him here
welcome and
i'm going to stop sharing my screen
and allow
y'gendra to share his
and there you have it
you're on mute
here we go
hello everybody uh thanks for joining
and thanks a lot stuart
and thanks a lot to everybody who has
joined at
nine o'clock i understand this will be
dinner time for most of you
i hope that this talk is probably as
engaging or as rewarding as the food
that you're enjoying
and with that i'll deep dive in
uh stuart i believe uh you guys can see
my screen
yes we can see your presentation
perfect
so
without much at all i'll just start off
with the basic premise
our you know we start talking about
fintech revolution now is that a
revolution or is that an exaggeration
and
that's something which has occupied the
minds of people considering the events
which have surrounded the industry
especially
in the last two years which have been
dominated by kubert
fintech also has become a really big
buzzword in india
now
angela strange who is a partner at
anderson horowitz which is a very well
known venture fund
she made a statement around a few years
back saying that every company will be a
fintech company
in a way
that statement is meant to illustrate
the importance of finding industry and
the
universality of the industry per se
and over the course of this presentation
we'll just try to
dissect
the truth in this statement and what are
the different drivers of the industry
and what will be the outlook going ahead
so if you look at let's say the year in
numbers
fintech industry has done amazingly well
it has reached an aggregate valuation of
close to usd 3.5 billion dollars uh 3.5
trillion dollars
uh
to put that into perspective the indian
gdp is somewhere around 5 trillion or so
so it's actually quite comparable to the
indian gdp and the fintech universe as a
whole
if you have to rank it within countries
it will probably be in the top 10 in the
world today
roughly around usd 125 billion dollars
was invested in this industry in the
year 2021 a record here by
a margin
this was led by funding across let's say
large mega rounds which are basically
classified as funding of usd 100 million
or above or early stage funding
2021 was a record whether it is in terms
of the amount of money which was
invested or the valuations that people
reached
or the number of unicorns that it
spawned
there were just about 193 unicorns which
were born
in the year 2021
which means that roughly every second
day there was a new unicorn getting
built
india coincidentally was the third
largest vc funding destination in 2021
he got the funding of close to let's say
9.3 billion close to 233 funding rounds
all in all a great year
and that well as extent you know
explains why
this particular industry has captured
the imagination of people and i believe
most of the people who are looking for
newer careers are looking for a change
in careers it has become probably the
most favored
industry segment
now let's look at
what are the different drivers and why
is it that fintech has done so well in
the world and especially in india we'll
try to look at both the demand drivers
as well as the supply drivers
on on the demand side we have let's say
three major drivers you would have young
population rising incomes and digital
enablement on the supply side we'll have
three uh core drivers like india digital
stack and the government push
uh uh satiated
as well as capital availability
now from demand side this i mean this is
something that probably most indians are
aware of but
it is still worth repeating we have a
young population
quite young as compared to any of the
other established countries and
coincidentally we also have the second
largest population at let's say 1.4
billion we are just second only to china
so this combination of young and large
population creates a significantly large
market
if you couple it with the fact that
india is still probably
one of the more open countries
it becomes a magnet for investment
destination
if you look at the average age indian
average age is just about 27 compared to
38 in both china as well as let's say
the usa that kind of illustrates the
youth of this population
and the fact that this population by its
very nature is much more attuned to
digital
means
almost everything in their life is now
actually being done digitally
from an income perspective
as you can clearly see
india has been growing pretty fast a
10.4 percent growth rate in income may
seem
less for people who probably don't have
the comparative statistics but if you
think about it most developed countries
typically tend to see a income increase
of just about let's say
one half to two percent
as an inside india growing at around ten
percent or so is a significant
achievement and a ten percent of growth
rate typically results in a doubling
of income in less than five years
so what we are witnessing is a
significant change in the entire
composition uh and the income
classification of this country every
five years or so
that kind of dramatic change by its very
nature
is conducive for
industries which are actually geared up
to capitalize on it
there are industries which are
traditional in nature which are very
slow-moving they will find it difficult
to survive in this climate fintech being
a tech enabled digital delivery
mechanism is perfectly placed to capture
this kind of a growth
dynamic now from a digital enablement
perspective and this is where the story
gets really interesting if you look at
it even today india has somewhere around
let's say 650 to 700 million people who
have access to internet this number is
expected to increase to close to a
billion people
by the year 2025
smartphone users we have just about
let's say 500 million people expected to
increase to 800 million people by 2025
and online transacting users basically
the holy grail of everything related to
either e-commerce or
let's say fintech
that number is expected to increase from
somewhere around let's say 250 300
million people to something like 750
million people in the next five years or
so
what we are talking about
is
in five years we'll be creating a
digitally enabled population which will
have a size
equivalent to or higher than the us has
currently
that's a mind-boggling number and that
to a large extent you know sums up the
growth dynamic which is driving this
industry
now from a digital enablement
perspective the other thing to note is
the fact that the indian population even
today
exhibits a very strong propensity to
actually
be
uh interested in let's say fintech
adoption or be interested in e-commerce
close to 87 of all people who are
digitally active actually have had
access to or have experienced fintech
products
that's a
significantly high number quite
comparable to china but
significantly higher than the 64 average
that you've seen
across the most of the developed
countries so all in all from a let's say
demand perspective whether it is young
population
uh
coupled with lesser digital enablement
as long as and
rising incomes albeit from a lower base
all three of these factors
put together an economy which is
which is significantly geared up for a
step change in fintech adoption in next
five years you would see that the world
would change dramatically i mean try to
imagine even in india five years back
the stuff that we have seen today and
the
scenario that we had five years back
that itself has changed so much and over
the next five years is
bound to change even more
now let's look at how the supply-side
drivers have
worked out
in this india is clearly an outlier like
we have an india digital stack which has
been
built largely by the government of india
now fintech across the world has largely
been a private enterprise
most of the countries which have
experienced this kind of growth
they've all piggybacked on the
rise of a few large companies which have
led to
somewhat let's say either a monopolistic
or an oligopolistic situation while in
india the government has been far more
let's say
forward thinking and they've actually
created tools which have allowed even
the smallest of the firm
to actually to have a
chance of competing in this market now
what are the different india digital
stack that the government has already
built out
we have a digital identity whether in
terms of aadhaar
that allows each and every
uh citizen in our country to actually
have
a means of let's say proving their own
identity then along with that we have
also created secure authentication
architecture there are multiple ways in
which you can do your know your customer
or kyc regulations so you have methods
like let's say digilocker or ckyc or
okyyc or ekyc
now for people who probably don't come
from this industry this is especially
important
simply because most of the products that
we are doing you would want to know with
whom are we like
associating with whom are we doing
business
if you have no
means of
let's say corroborating the identity as
well as the address of a customer then
we'll have a challenge but by coming up
with secure authentication architecture
which is freely accessible to each and
every firm whether large or small the
indian government has created a
significantly
competitive level playing field
along with that we have
different payment systems which have
created a cashless transactions
uh stack
you have different modes of payments
like upi imps neff
e-sign which allow people to actually
transact
as less contract
without any physical interventions
today
we can actually transfer money from
one person to another from a person to a
merchant from a person to a person
any means
electronically and at any denomination
for the matter is you can transfer
amounts as low as one rupee to as high
as let's say even 10 crores using just
about any of these digital means
available
then we have the consent based data
transfer
now whenever we are let's say doing
business with somebody one of the key
requirements is our understanding of the
customer our understanding of the
customer is a function of the data that
we have about the customer
typically
you have
over here also we have digital
transactions enabled platforms which
provide you with let's say bureau data
bank data or gst
and
multiple other information that we can
get by actually taking the consent of
the particular person
hansen part is quite important and if
you look at it the indian government has
a as well as the regulatory agencies
have been very very
activist in
enforcing this consent based
architecture to ensure that the industry
grows from on a sustainable level
and each and every customer has a right
to actually safeguard their data and
share only when they feel it is
necessary
if you put all of this together today in
india you can actually give out a loan
in
less than a minute
he as a company are actually already
doing it
we
are enabling purchase of smartphones
which happens
in less than a minute and all
by just giving let's say a few
identification information and
everything gets done electronically
along with this the so these are more
the established uh digital stacks
along with this the government is
working on
a whole lot of other initiatives which
are going to revolution revolutionize
the way in which our industry is
functioning a few of them would be
account aggregators which will actually
take this consent based data transfer
architecture to a newer level people
will be able to control for how long do
they give information to whom they gave
information and they'll be able to
translate all information that they
would want to any of the people
uh we are also working on a near
national health stack which will draw
which will combine all the health
information about the person we are also
working on on dc which is our open
network for digital commerce which will
actually be probably a first in a kind
open stack environment for enabling
e-commerce so
we are not resting on our laurels fact
of the matter is the public stack
availability in india is increasing
exponentially and that
actually gives most of the smaller
players a very very
significant competitive advantage and a
chance to compete with the larger
players and to provide
services in a digital manner in a very
convenient way and to spin tech or
consumer businesses
they operate on what we would call let's
say instant transactions
or
the transaction time would be let's say
a day or two
typically fintech
lending businesses they operate on
deferred term payments
that those payments could
the time duration in those payments
could be as low as let's say a month or
15 days to as high as 10 years 15 years
20 years
a digital home loan could typically run
for even let's say 30 years or so
so the time becomes quite different
credit losses
in your classical businesses
credit losses are simply not there if
you're only delivering the services once
you have been paid chances are quite low
the
the
i would say closest analog to credit
loss would probably be to some extent in
the e-commerce field where you have cash
on delivery and you have returns of
products and typically you
do lose some amount of money because the
products have been returned but it's
still not a significant amount of money
that is at stake there while in fintech
you can have actually quite
high losses
and a lot of companies have also gone a
belly up because they have not really
understood that this is a model which is
quite different your ability to
understand customers and make sure that
you give money only to customers who are
likely to pay you back is what will
differentiate a good fintech from a bad
one
i mean as the famous thing goes
typically you know the joke between nbc
and fintech is
nbfc is basically a fintech which is
profitable
and fintech is basically
an embassy which is loss making
so
from a regulations perspective
you have
consumer internet businesses typically
run with generic or very or let's say
low entry barrier regulations while
lending is la is a highly regulated
industry so your ability to comply with
regulations whilst providing convenience
and security to customers becomes a key
factor in success
then the simple financial model
by its very nature consumer internet
businesses they will typically tend to
have
high unit
profitability and low leverage
while the lending business by its very
nature
is a
low unit economics model it operates by
its very nature with extremely high
leverage
so all put together you can clearly see
that the lending business is a very very
different business to run it's not an
easy business and that's why we see
significant level of failures in this
industry
but by that very nature that makes the
industry far more attractive because if
you can get it right
the scalability inherent in this
business is extremely high
now let's look at okay what are the
different segments that typically
we see in fintech lending we have
unsecured consumer lending this is
something which has
been quite popular in this country and
the products are largely around let's
say cards or bnpl which provide mostly
short-term financing or term loans now
these term loans could typically be
duration ranging from as low as let's
say three months to as high as five
years
then you have unsecured business lending
unsecured business lending once again
the form factors could be simply cards
you could have business spending cards
or you could have invoice financing
where let's say you are either you are
buying from some place or you are
selling to somebody that invoice could
be financed
could be let's say discounted by a
lender and money could be advanced to
you against that particular invoice
then you have revenue based financing
which is simply a means of let's say
providing
state capital to uh small businesses on
the basis of the revenues that they are
making to a large extent this is an area
which is trying to make it much more
easier for companies to get access to
capital on the basis of the growth that
they are witnessing in their operations
and fourth is your classical product
which is a term loan this is simply
any unsecured lending with tom uh
ranging from anywhere between let's say
three months to five years and then
you have quite a few fintechs which are
operating in the asset based lending
market
gold loans has become a significant
product
as you are well aware india is a country
which has significant
love with gold
almost all the households carry
significant gold holdings we have the
we have the largest holding of gold in
the entire world
and companies have come up with ideas of
how to
make sure that this gold can be used for
liquidity purposes
hypothecate the gold to get some money
against it and it becomes a relatively
safe transaction for everybody
considering the fact that it is
relatively quite easy to actually sell
the gold and get your money back then we
have vehicle financing typically two
wheelers or four wheelers which are now
getting done electronically
and then you have this real estate based
loans where either you have a home loan
or a loan against property or home
equity line of credit
so if you look at it the
gamut of services available on the land
is significantly large it's an amazingly
large market
and
there are significant uh narrow areas or
niche areas that fintechs can focus on
and try to derive
growth or success out of it
so that to a large extent you know sums
up the presentation but before we end i
would just like to take a couple of
minutes just to give you an idea of
the company that i'm working with so
proteum started just about let's say two
years back we are a fairly young company
we operate across in fact most of these
business lines we actually do unsecured
consumer lending we do unsecured
business lending also
and we are interested based lending as
well
we are a company which employs close to
1300 people we are present in somewhere
on let's say 50 odd locations
and
we
significantly large see let's say seed
round
say that we probably raise this
the single biggest seed round
of close to 200 million dollars in
in this country
we are on the lookout for young
enterprising and smart people across
analytics
technology business everywhere so feel
free to reach out to me or to any of the
team members on linkedin you can find us
all there and please feel free to reach
out if you feel that you would like to
work with us
wonderful um
thank you for that
kendra it's
really an eye-opening um overview of
fintech and its
impact
on
india's development but also the
changing of the world in in this
post-pandemic digital transformation
mode it's something
i'm based in california
although i worked for simply learn which
is based in bangalore
um but
here in the united states we have only
just recently started seeing
things like neobanks
being heavily advertised um one of the
things that i noticed
in your presentation
about
micro
contextual insurance is that
it's not
a new idea in that
many years ago if you were at an airport
in the united states or in many other
parts of the world
there would be a kiosk that would let
you fill in
a flight insurance
form put some money in the envelope drop
it in the kiosk
and if anything happened on the flight
insurance would pay off also
you rent a vehicle in the united states
you have options to do uh
collision damage waiver of the vehicle
or lost damage uh waivers for your
contents of the vehicle and that type of
thing so
that old concept is now being extended
um
to
all types of
microtransactions isn't it
yeah i agree stuart and to la election i
mean if you look at the way the fintech
industry are developed it's not that the
business models are unique
they're just trying to do the same
things
using digital means changing some of the
things along the way
and
making probably possible some other
things which are not possible simply
because of physical world
so in india it's more about let's say if
you take loans
now
when if for a physical bank giving a
loan of let's say 5000 rupees or maybe
let's say just about let's say 50 or 100
dollars is very tough
but if you have pure digital means it
becomes possible but the basic business
of giving loans still remains the same
yeah
um
it's also interesting that
you know as i just mentioned with the
idea of
the point of transaction
micro insurance
uh you now have the ability for point of
transaction lending so you can have
instant credit decisions being made
somebody who's
at a
retail outlet or other
place where they're making a transaction
so that's a
quite a different
quite a different phenomenon
because as you say
there's no way a physical or traditional
bank would be able to handle a credit
application within
the matter of a few seconds yes
so
we have a couple of questions that have
come in about blockchain technology and
its role in fintech um
and
whether fintech and cryptocurrency have
a relationship so
could you comment on that uh sure i
think this is from sharafatul um
this blockchain required in fintech
bitcoin cryptocurrency transactions
so to a large extent look blockchain is
basically the building block on which so
it's more like a decentralized ledger
what we are trying to do over there is
to create
a system by which
you are
creating ownership without anybody being
aware of it now if you look at any of
the cryptos yes underlying they will
always use a blockchain
whether it is a bitcoin or ethereum or
india or solana any of those things they
are definitely using blockchain
okay
um
kartik who came in from our linkedin
audience uh
asks how do you see the future of b2b
lending in india especially invoice
financing what used to be called
factoring in the united
[Music]
states factoring in india has been there
for a long time
but it's only now that it has started
acquiring problems and uh from a
regulations perspective now that rbi has
actually allowed uh every nbfc to do
factoring the market has become much
more clearer earlier used to one needed
separate
let's say license to operate as a factor
now
those
the licensing regime has been actually
made easier the second is the rise of
b2b platforms
look at it there are companies like
let's say iran or their companies like
let's say flipkart or amazon
all of them are operating a significant
level of b2b commerce all of them have
significa
and we actually are significantly active
in that field uh
almost all the sellers on any of the b2b
platforms they actually require invoice
financing the amount of volumes that we
ourselves are seeing is immense and we
have merely touched the
best let's say 10 or 15 percent of the
population
so
yeah so from a pure let's say
but if you look at the way uh
most of the entire let's say supply
chain across let's say industries like
let's say
uh whether it is fmcg or consumer
durables
that is yet to be mapped so from
according to me
we have barely covered just about one to
two percent of the market
the remaining 98 percent is yet to be
tapped
um
we have a
question from devonch who asked if
the growth of
fintech directly depends on
the population itself growing or the
increase of user
internet users within the population
actually both because to some extent
both of them are actually interrelated
now uh if you have a country i mean take
countries in europe
over there population growth rates are
fairly low
internet adoption has increased but it
has now reached a plateau so if the
actual population doesn't grow and you
have already reached more or less high
penetration levels then the industry
can't grow in a country like india
both the factors are quite high
you have growth which is coming from
internet adoption of the same population
but the population itself keeps
increasing so what you would have what
you would call a multiplier effect
um
so
vishal asks what's the revenue model for
companies like upr payment gateways
how are they uh
how are they earning revenue
in
facilitating payments
okay so
now that's a pretty interesting question
actually if you think about it the three
or four large players in the
upi payment uh
companies are
phone pay paytm google
to some extent amazon and whatsapp
now all of them
because the government because there's
no merchant discount rate
on upi you actually can't charge for
transactions so what are the different
ways in which you can still make money
one is
if you have let's say 200 million people
or 300 million people who are
transacting with you
then you get to see what are the kind of
let's say transactions that they're
making depending on those transactions
you can start selling value-added
services those could be
let's say an insurance or lending
or let's say wealth tech products
or even insurance products if you have
those people listed on to you
there is no i mean there is no death of
opportunities with which you can
interact with the customer
all of these
there is a reason why all of these
companies have spent so much of money in
trying to acquire the customers once
they have the customers who are actually
staying with them and who are sticky
then that becomes the default platform
through which you actually do the cross
sell
that to a large extent is the promise of
the model and that's how the money would
be made and of course they are also
hoping that over a period of time
the mdrs will probably come back
you might be able to charge for
transactions or you might be able to
create
let's say value-added services around it
we have a question i think it's probably
on a lot of people's minds arnold asks
what is the most high-paying job profile
in the fintech industry
actually if you think about it
one is
if you do if you're really good you get
paid quite well in across all the
disciplines like in our company if i
look at it whether it is tech or
analytics or business development or
strategy
the top performers get paid almost
equally
you just have to be pretty good at it
but considering the constraints on tech
currently in india i would say the tech
guys actually get paid quite well
analytics guys probably even more simply
because
analytics is a fairly
uh
emerging field
we didn't used to have analytics 10
years back it is largely a last decade
invention
yeah i think that the
history of analytics is interesting
because
it's existed for a long time but
it hasn't become
you know
democratized
until recently where
the availability of tools for
visualization for data analysis for
modeling and making inferences
all of that has evolved so rapidly in
the last decade
that
now
it's not a matter of going to some
specialist firm and asking them to do
analytics for you it's a it's a tool
that people can operate
essentially from a desktop and and still
get
uh things that would have taken
weeks for a consultant to produce
in you know in decades past so
uh what are they what are the
kinds of tech skills that are most
important
to
a company like proteum
well to a large extent we actually
require
let's say
full stack orders or we are specifically
interested in people who actually have
expertise in either of python or java
the python usage has increased
considerably we actually use it
extensively across both the tech as well
as the analytics domains
um we had a question about neobanks and
nihal asked can a neo bank operate as a
multiple bank aggregator
uh as of now no because most of the bank
i mean you can have one-to-one
relationship with the bank from a
let's say if you want to operate as
multiple bank aggregators a few people
are trying it but one of the ways in
which you could do that is if let's say
you went with an account aggregator
license an account aggregator would
typically be able to do it but yes this
is a
problem that a lot of people are trying
to solve because this is
this has significant business potential
yeah i i've noticed that
in recent years pools have come out like
uh the company in the u.s mint which is
part of
um
it's part of one of the the
major
early fintech companies that was dealing
with mortgages and and other types of
intuit i'm sorry
into it was the
uh
online
accounting service and then it's
branched out and one of its divisions
mint
uh gives you your
overview of all your accounts
um but it doesn't act as an aggregator
in the sense that you can't transact
between accounts from it
you can just see what your
what your different balances and
payments are so
um
udaya in the linkedin audience asks what
is the scope of a career in financial
advisory he touched on the notion of
wealth management
in fintech
so how is that impact careers and
financial advisor
the career in financial advisory now
if you look at from a pure uh
the way the classical industry worked
financial advisory was largely a means
by which
you would have more like interpersonal
connections and you would try to advise
you know few clients at a time
financial advisory in the fintech domain
is more about trying to come up with
mass market solutions so
what what call let's say a robo advisors
or coming up with let's say models which
try to
give a solution to a lot of people
or from a mass customization perspective
so over here probably using analytics to
do financial advisory is something which
will probably grow far far more faster
than your traditional method of taking
one client at a time and trying to give
them the best advice possible
um
rohit has a question i think i can
answer which is uh are there courses
being offered in india related
blockchain for chartered accountants
um one thing i can mention is that
simply learn itself offers
courses in partnership with different
universities and one of them is iit
kanpur which is the home of the
indian national blockchain project
so
that's a suitable course i think is an
overview of blockchain technology
um
are you agenda can you
recommend any others
i don't know i think
that definitely is probably the one of
the best courses to go around with
thank you um
and
we have a question about what's the
future of fintech in africa
once again i mean africa actually from a
micro lending space or on a micro saving
space they have been at the forefront of
it i mean uh
kenya nigeria both of these
as well as less in south africa
we have seen significantly large
companies emerging out of that and
that's one of the good success stories
excellent i know that there's a
firm called kiva that
facilitates microlending from
people in the u.s and europe to to help
african
and other
micro con micro lending consumers
to start business that type of thing
it's a very interesting
way of
channeling
um resources in a highly productive way
rather than
giving clarity so um
we have a question from puja that asks
about sashatization
and
is that something that's helpful in
reducing cost or is it being driven by
something else
it is largely driven by actually
increasing the addressable market
so imagine if you had to let's say reach
out to somebody so if you are let's say
a savings company now typically uh
investments in equity securities or
investment in mutual funds they would
have let's say higher ticket sizes but
what if you wanted to allow somebody who
probably
in let's say gets just about 10 rupees a
day
right now
it'll be difficult for him to actually
invest because he'll have to wait for
till he gets to a thousand rupees or
something so that he can invest in it
but
you know
micro saving companies will actually
allow them to accumulate this and try to
do this so this way you are getting
giving access to somebody who probably
didn't have access to it before
so it's more about this expanding the
total addressable market
um
it's
it's kind of the opposite of the
tendency in consumer products in some
places to go to
warehouse stores where
people are buying in bulk quantities and
large containers
to get a discount but when you're
looking at people who don't have the
resources to do that or don't have the
need
it's uh
you go to the other end of the scale and
are able to buy single user or
small quantity
products and services that fit your
current need
um
we have a question about the scope of
cyber security in fintech
which is uh
i'm not even going to try to to
say aravind's full name because i will
stumble but arvin asks this question
about what is the scope of cyber
security infection
significantly large considering that
large parts of fintech are actually
belong in the regulated domain now
making sure that the customer data is
secure
and people are able to do transactions
in a secure manner is one of the
preeminent
requirements that we as regulated
entities have
so
we are always on the lookout for people
who can actually
help us in
protecting
both our customers as well as ourselves
from malicious attacks and if you look
at it
as uh
digital commerce as well as a fintech
has evolved fraudsters have come in and
digital frauds have kept on increasing
so
having the best quality cyber security
experts is i would say a precondition
for running a successful digital
business today
we have uh time for just a couple more
questions
one of them is
from um who says someone with no
experience in finance the finance
industry
where would be a good place to start
wants to get into fintech
uh well if you have let's say tech or
analytics experience then probably a
lack of finance would still not wear
hindrance
uh if even if you have let's say a good
bda experience that also works so i
would say knowing finance is good but
it's not really something which will
prevent you from embarking on a fintech
career all you have to find out is okay
what are the other core skills that you
have
take some understanding of the industry
and considering the massive growth that
the industry is experiencing
getting a job is relatively easy today
and the last question i can take is uh
what are your thoughts on the role and
impact of smart automation and ai
smart automation definitely a lot now ai
i tend to have a slightly different
opinion
that a lot of people especially in the
printing industry and in the industry
that i'm operating in we all talk about
ai while in reality what we are using
are basically
to a large extent machine learning
models which technically can't be called
ai these are all models which are
probably just you can call it let's say
non-linear models
but it's definitely not ai in fact ai as
a term is actually quite
widely used but quite widely misused as
well
2ai is
very difficult to build and its
commercial implica uh
implications are actually quite few and
far between today but smart automation
definitely
if you look at it bulk of what we are
doing is all process based making sure
that all these processes can
run automatically is at the core of our
operations
great so that
takes care of the questions and the
answers and let me
go to the next
poll and i'll
put that up in just a second
so we go here
so allow me to start this
and this is about
the different
skills
that people in the audience
might be interested
in acquiring
so we've heard about different skills
that the fintech industry
needs
um in different ways the fintech
industry will
impact uh pretty much everything in the
digital world
so what are the
tools that you want to add to your
personal tool kit
the digital domain
and more you know most importantly when
do you want to get started doing that
give you another 15 seconds or so
you have about five seconds to get your
answers in and finalized
all right and i'll share the poll
results
as you can see again dr the
i think the most popular category is
business and project management
um but also data science machine
learning
and across the board and various other
aspects of technology and it's good to
see that about a third of the audience
is interested in getting started
right away and another 20
at least within the next three months so
with that i'm going to
say thank you to yagendra for being here
i will put into the chat here
your linkedin
address if that's all right
of course
and give me a moment to do that
all right it's in the
chat window you can find the link to
yogendra's linkedin
and
thank you again so much for being here
you gendra um
really appreciate it it was a fantastic
presentation
and a lot of very um
cutting questions from the audience that
showed that there's a really big
interest in
fintech um i want to
finish by just mentioning two things one
is our skill up program
which is a free program from simplyland
that covers a number of different skills
in the digital domain
and
this one is a free self learning program
that allows you to earn certificates in
various skills
it's basically a simplified version of
our
uh online
interactive courses that include live
virtual classrooms and
hands-on labs
skillup doesn't have those elements but
it does allow you to self-study in
hundreds of different digital skills so
i've put the link into the chat and
i'll make plugged for the next
general webinar we're doing and this
actually applies directly to what
yogendra had mentioned about
process and
our next speaker on wednesday
may 11th is
laura hendricks who is the head of rpa
and process automation at
first horizon bank
uh in the united states um
and she will talk about how she's used
lean principles to direct her work
both
in
applying lean principles to the
processes she re-engineers but also
applying lean principles to manage a
team
and
she'll give you some advice about how
you can do the same
in your work in your career so
that will be wednesday may 11th same
time on 9 pm india at 8 30 a.m pacific
and 11 30 a.m eastern here in north
america
and
with that
i want to say one final thank you to
yagendra a thank you to our audience for
being here
and i'd like to invite everybody
to follow us on our social channels
at simply learn on facebook and twitter
and
simply learn
on linkedin
and we look forward to seeing you at
future
simply learn events but we also look
forward to seeing you
in our learner community
again thanks jagendra
thanks to it and thanks everybody for
joining
you